hey what's going on ladies and gentlemen
I want to start off the video by telling
you that I'm going to do a giveaway it's
Christmas Eve and I'm in a Christmas
spirit so I want to give something back
to you guys for supporting my channel
and my gift to you will be any season of
The Game of Thrones series that you want
on blu-ray or DVD whichever one you want
and I will let you pick whatever season
you like the most if you like season one
or season six the most I'll let you pick
whichever one if you win and I will mail
it to you for Christmas all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber of my
channel and you will get an entry it's
pretty simple and if you are already a
subscriber to my channel I will give you
two entries and I will randomly select
the winner on January 1st and mail it to
you right away just as soon as you tell
me what season it is you want the most
and where to send it to so let the games
begin ladies and gentlemen and in
today's video it's going to be another
prediction video and I'm going to give
you a fair warning right up front there
will be season 7 spoilers in this video
so now that you know let's get started
and today I want to talk about Cersei
Lannister you're on and you're a Greyjoy
and those two [ __ ] from Dorne and
what I think is likely to happen to them
next year now that they are being held
captive so let me start off with
refreshing everyone's memory on how we
ended up where we are currently at when
you're on Greyjoy showed back up at the
Iron Islands he got straight to work and
murdered his brother immediately that
way he could put himself in line to
taking over control the Iron Islands in
the entire Greyjoy fleet but obviously
this didn't sit well with Yara and Theon
it was obvious that you're on murdered
their father Baylon considering they
found his body right after your on
return to the Iron Islands and he had
that big cut on his face that pretty
much just gave away that he was in a
fight and that act alone would make
anyone want to avenge the death of their
father even if your father is a [ __ ]
and was killed by your uncle it wouldn't
matter but then you're on thought he
should be king of the Iron Islands as
well when he clearly hasn't been there
putting in the same work that Yara had
been doing but electing a queen isn't
something that comes easy and even
though Yara had the respect of most of
the men Euron was chosen
over her you're on promise to form an
alliance with Danny and by combining
their forces he promised to deliver them
the Seven Kingdoms and let's be honest
who wouldn't want that but Fiona Nora
knew that if you're on became King it
would be trouble for them so during the
ceremony Yura and Fiona took off with
the Greyjoy fleet and sailed straight
the marine could tell Danny about
Euron's plan and that's when Yara gave
Danny a counteroffer and promised to
help her in return the Iron Islands
would have their independence which
Danny agreed to do under one condition
Daenerys said that they could no longer
rape and Reeve even though that was
their way of life
Yara had to agree to you know be
civilized what she did so now we have a
Greyjoy in Targaryen alliance but this
isn't going to be taken lightly
after Euron was named king and he
realized that yar and Fiona took off
with the fleet he was furious and ready
to murder them so he told his men to
build him a thousand ships
so you're on Greyjoy is preparing for
war and once he finds out that they ran
straight to Daenerys and stole his plan
he's going to be even more pissed but
during all this
there was another Alliance being formed
at the same time to strengthen the
Targaryen force Lady Olenna Tyrell and
ilaria san had this little secret
meeting to join forces to take down
Cersei Lannister and that's when various
steps in and offers them fire and blood
so Daenerys now has the support of the
Dothraki the unsullied the Tyrells Dorne
and a fraction of the Greyjoy's plus all
their ships combined which makes for a
pretty damn impressive force all
together so Danny now has an army in a
fleet large enough to cause some real
damage and destruction in Westeros and
finally have a real shot at taking back
the Iron Throne for the Targaryen 's
which is something that has been on her
mind for quite some time and she has
went through hell to get to this point
and she isn't going to let anything stop
her and finally at the end of season six
Dany and all of her forces finally set
sail for Westeros and that's when we got
that beautiful shot of her entire fleet
with her three dragons flying above
providing her with some aerial support
so
Lannister is going to be in for a pretty
damn big surprise when she realizes how
large this army is that is coming for
her in her throne not only does the
Nerys want to take the iron throne for
herself but Tyrion is also there who's
probably wanting to kill a sister at
this point as well she's won in Tyrion
dead ever since he was a baby and her
dream was almost fulfilled during his
trial by combat which Oberyn Martell
lost resulting in Tyrion being sentenced
to death and we know Cersei purposely
chose the mountain knowing that he would
win which would lead to Tyrians death
but that actually came back to bite
Cersei right in the ass because killing
Oberyn Martell wasn't going to go
unnoticed in a lorry and his daughters
are out for blood and their first victim
Circe's daughter Marcella in next stop
King's Landing
I think Ilario would personally love to
take Circe's life with her own bare
hands but those aren't the only people
with Dany that once Cersei dead lady
Olenna Tyrell wants vengeance as well
her and Cersei never got along that was
made very clear very early so much so
that lady Olenna conspired with
Littlefinger to take down Joffrey just
to ensure the protection of her
granddaughter Margaery Tyrell but Cersei
doesn't just let [ __ ] slide either and
Cersei wasn't about to just sit on the
sidelines while this new young beautiful
Queen took her spot next to the Iron
Throne in wedging a gap between her and
her son Tommen oh no no no no no no
given the chance Cersei would take
everyone down and after Tommen declared
that there would no longer be any trial
by combat
Cersei knew that if she stood trial for
her crimes she would lose and she wasn't
about to let that happen so she had the
courthouse turned into a ticking time
bomb ready to murder everyone in her
path including her prosecutors in any
Tyrell she could include in her master
plan of death and destruction in lady
Elena loved her grandchildren just as
much as Cersei loved her own children
and the one thing that Elena and Cersei
have in common is they're willing to go
to any extreme for their loved ones I
can't wait to see these two foes go
head-to-head in a season seven showdown
King's Landing is going to turn into the
greatest fireworks display the Seven
Kingdoms have ever seen and lucky for us
we have front-row seats
damnit I'm getting excited so now that a
table is set and Danny has all over
pieces in place for an all-out war on
Westeros and considering Cersei isn't
going to just hand her over the keys to
the kingdom I expect to see a war of
epic proportions but there is only one
thing missing
Cersei needs a new alliance after Cersei
wiped out the major heirs of house
Tyrell
the Lannisters no longer have their
support and now that Walder Frey is dead
it's hard to say what role the phrase
are going to play from here on out so
who is out there that is willing to go
into an all-out war with Daenerys who
can be just as crazy as Cersei Lannister
that would be your on Greyjoy ladies and
gentlemen your on Greyjoy now needs an
alliance as well now that your and Filan
stole his plan and teamed up with Danny
you're on is going to need someone to
help him take them head-on and this
leads us right into our season seven
spoilers tons of information has came
out ever since HBO went into production
for its seventh season of Game of
Thrones and a report came out back in I
think it was September that said you're
on Greyjoy will attack Danny's fleet as
she is sailing to King's Landing and
during this attack you're on and his men
actually killed to the sand snakes and
take Yara Gloria and her daughter
prisoner and Euron might not even
actually know how valuable his Dorne
prisoners actually are but when he
delivers them all to Cersei she would
probably be more than happy to join
forces what you're on she could
definitely use his help in his fleet
especially if he is actually able to
build those thousand ships and what the
most recent league set photos we are
definitely going to see some variation
of this take place in the photos we see
euron greyjoy
riding his horse through the streets of
King's Landing and behind him he has
you're a Greyjoy chained up as his
prisoner walking right behind him as he
probably heads right for Cersei and this
is when things are going to get very
interesting and I'm going to tell you
right now glorious and and her daughter
tyene sand are in deep deep doo-doo
Cersei is going to show no mercy on his
woman we know how much Cersei loved her
children and we know exactly what she is
capable of and given the fact that
ilaria poisoned Circe's daughter Gloria
and Tye
we'll never leave King's Landing alive I
promise you that Euron is going to
parade them through the city and strut
right up to Cersei Lannister and offer
her these prisoners and maybe even his
fleet just like he plan to do for Dany
and when Cersei sees ilaria her eyes are
going to light up like wildfire Cersei
is going to accept this offer just to
get her hands on her now I know you're
on said he was going to murder his niece
and nephew what she still could do at
some point but I don't see that
happening anytime soon
Yara could be used to bargain with Dany
made her an agreement and certainly
isn't going to want her newfound friend
to die so I could see them using Yara as
like a Power Move or to at least keep
Danny at bay for a while
but I don't see Cersei or Joran ever
giving her back regardless or letting
her go free I think if you are I wants
to get out immediately she's going to
have to escape which isn't likely but
I'm going to throw a prediction out
there that some of you are probably
going to say I'm absolutely batshit
crazy for saying but I'm going to say it
anyway I think if anyone rescues Yara
it's going to be her brother Theon now
he may have help with him when he does
this but fian is definitely going to
want to lead the charge and trust me I
know Theon is a broken man who's a
coward and he can't fight and he's
scared of his own shadow I know I can't
dispute any of that stuff but I think
vielen is going to complete his story
arc one way or another and I think he
can do this by getting his sister back
now he's definitely going to pay the
price for allowing her to get captured
in the first place because we've seen
any set photos that were leaked you can
see Theon's getting his ass kicked by
the Ironborn and like I said before I
think this is happening because he
didn't try hard enough to keep y'all
from being taken
we know the Ironborn or hardman and
feelin's going to be punished for that
but this is going to motivate him and
fuel him to man the eff up and put in
some work Theon is going to go from
privileged Ward to stark enemy to
tortured a broken man and eventually a
hero when it looks like that couldn't be
any further from the truth
I know you think feeling a hero like
you're right but we've already get a
little taste of this when he helps Sansa
escape from the bones and
think we're Yara failed in her attempt
to save fee on when he was a prisoner
I think feelin is going to do good on
his attempt to save his sister while she
is in King's Landing and he may even die
doing it but I think if anyone saves
Jorah it's going to be her brother
because no one really expects him to
step up and do something like this and
go into enemy territory behind enemy
lines willing to fight now this leads me
to those two [ __ ] from Dorne and
let's face it folks they're doomed this
Dorne plot has been absolutely atrocious
the entire time
except for oberyn's time and Kings
Landing like he was phenomenal but
everything else has been hard to watch
and at this point I think Dan and Dave
have begun operation extermination and
they're going to make the Dorne story go
extinct as soon as possible which is why
they already started killing off all
those characters as much as Dan and Dave
want to make this story their own now
that they are off the books
they still want to please the fans and
they know the Dorne plot has probably
received the most negative criticism and
we know they get emotional when it comes
to criticism which is why we get a
terrible scene like this during the play
letting us know exactly how they felt
about our opinions but I think the
[ __ ] from Dorne are going to go out
in style like I said before Cersei is
going to show no mercy on a Lauria for
killing her daughter I expect to see a
Lauria and tyene to die by season seven
episode to very quickly next year and
ilaria is probably going to die in a
very horrific way she's going to be
tortured but before that happens I could
see Cersei actually killing her daughter
right in front of olaria just so she
knows how it feels but I'm afraid of
Lauria isn't going to get off that easy
oh no no no no no no no she's going to
pay in a very slow and painful way we
could see something reminiscent of the
type of torture Cersei had the mountain
due to the septa or she could even have
the mountain smash her head like a grape
just like she did with Oberyn Martell I
think the possibilities are endless but
either way I think her death is going to
be glorious and we can finally put the
final nail in the coffin on this Dorne
plot once and for all to free up time
for the characters that are actually
interesting and liked by those people
but I definitely think this is going to
be the start to a beautiful new
relationship between euron greyjoy and
Cersei Lannister
I think the season 7 introduction could
get very exciting and set the tone for
the type of roller-coaster ride we
should get this year given all the main
characters are now on the same continent
personally I can all wait so comment
below and tell me what you think I know
some of you are going to think I'm
[ __ ] but don't worry I still love
you guys anyway also guys I want to do a
season 7 prediction video Q&A video and
if I get enough questions I will post
the video tomorrow on Christmas
guaranteed just leave me a comment below
and just title the question QA or use a
hashtag and put QA whatever you want to
do but make sure all the questions are
season 7 related that way I can answer
the question with given a season 7
prediction and I'll put it in a video
but anyways thank you all very much for
taking the time to watch this video and
all my other ones I hope everyone has a
great Christmas and if I get enough
questions for the QA I will see you
tomorrow sometime in the comment section
also don't forget about to giveaway guys
subscribe to the channel and you get a
chance to win any game of thrones season
you want thanks a lot guys Merry
Christmas and I will see you tomorrow
probably bye